welcome to the heavy spoiler show I'm
your host Paul aka the guy who makes
every shot hit like John Wick and
chapter 4 is now out throughout this
video we're going to be breaking down
where the film Keanu leaves things off
and also talking about the future of the
franchise and it will be recapping what
happens in the movie that post-credits
scene and also talking about where
things are going to be leading to in the
sequels heavy spoilers ahead and if you
haven't had a chance to check it out and
I highly recommend that you check out
now please shoot that thumbs up button
and also make sure you subscribe if you
never miss our breakdowns oh now the way
thanks for clicking this I am close
you and I left a good life behind a long
time ago my friend
I'll actually rewatched the first three
John Wick movies this week in the lead
up to today and I think we have to stop
putting this franchise up there in the
conversation of the best of all time
there's very few film series that have
four bangers back to back like this and
yeah it's time to stop putting Keanu
Reeves on the Mount Rushmore of movies
in case you need a quick catch up the
first movie picked up with ax Hitman
John Wick who just watched his wife pass
away from a terminal illness leaving him
a dog so that he had something to love
Jon's wife Helen hoped that he could
move on unfortunately though he was
pulled back into the game after his car
was stolen and the puppy was killed by
Lily Allen's brother launching a Revenge
Mission Against The Mob John got revenge
and a new dog but it wasn't too long
until his Services were acquired once
more owing a blood out the gangster
Santino de Antonio he was tasked with
killing his sister so that he could
claim his seat at the high table his
left her forces against him along with
santinos who is trying to tie up all the
Loose Ends from the job after putting a
seven million dollar bounty on his head
Wick ended up killing Santino and
Continental grounds and this left him
excommunicado with the entire world out
for him Wick Escape New York to
Casablanca which is way met back up with
his friend Sophia the high table
adjudicator went around punishing all
that had aided Wick and this included
the Bowery King and also the director
whilst this was going on Wick made his
way to the Elder who we learned sat
above the high table he said he'd
forgive him if he killed Winston and
remained loyal to the high table for the
remainder of his life which Wick agreed
to by handing over his wedding ring
along with his finger that was all a
[__] lie though and Upon returning to
Winston Wick refused to kill him along
with the Continental forces they made a
stand against zero and all of the people
that the high table sent after them
after besting them the adjudicator
offered a parlay to Winston and then he
shot Wick which sent him over the edge
of the hotel Wick was secretly delivered
to the Bowery King and together the two
decided to team up against the high
table and all its over organization and
that takes us into chapter four in which
we followed the man who killed three
people with a [__] pencil
Ben since with John with killing the
eldest replacement who tells him that
the only way he will find peace is in
death is very much foreshadows the
events of the ending and it also
explains why Jon has to participate in a
duel a high table is described as being
like a Hydra that if you cut off one
head another one will appear just in the
same way that the Elder's been replaced
all of the members of the high table can
be as well and thus Jon will run out of
bullets before they run out of heads
movie in a way is very much about
Redemption and Diving the Fate that's
being given to him Jon is said to be
someone who brings death to everything
that he touches but in the end he gives
Kanan New Life along with his daughter
this is a similar sort of thing to what
Sophia had in the third film then that
we discover that she too had a daughter
that she couldn't have a life with it
due to the demands of the high table
John sees firsthand how much this quest
for revenge is killing his friends and
in the end he realizes that it all stops
if he passes away which we see happen in
the final few scenes I will be talking
about whether I think the character is
actually dead or not later on but
there's a lot going on in the movie that
I think we have to talk about first to
give context to those final few scenes
Connor Reeves has talked with The
Hollywood Reporter about what that
ending really meant and there's a lot to
discuss in both terms of symbolism and
metaphor the John Wick Series has always
been laced with the idea of Mythology
and this is seen in every single film
Tyrone pulls from ancient mythology Wick
pulled rosary beads out of a book at the
start of three Dante's Inferno was
mentioned and Winston was given seven
days to get his Affairs in order Jon
himself is based on John the Baptist and
the baptism is very much seen as a
cleansing in which past sins are
forgotten there's also the idea that he
goes on a sort of Jesus Journey
throughout the four films with the first
being his birth or rebirth after he's
found a new life the second is his
Ascension the third culminates with his
apparent death and the fourth deals with
his resurrection before he finally
passes away after having become a savior
figure he also has his disciples too
like his servant Winston and even though
Lauren's Fishburne dresses like the a
pigeon lady from Home Alone 2 he is seen
as a king a Kane is a really interesting
villain too and he's basically like
stick from Daredevil also that ending
scene reminded me a lot of the ending
from no way home and there's actually a
lot of things in this that reminded me
of Marvel movies maybe I'm just obsessed
with them because I'm a loser anyway
like John Kane got out of the life but
he had to give up his eyes in order to
do this once the high table threatened
his daughter though he's pulled back
into it and symbolically he blindly
follows the high tables orders without
question Kane has a deeper layer to it
as well as Kane killed his brother Abel
in the Bible similar how Kane here kills
his quote-unquote brother shimazu now
John's Deeds haven't gone unpunished and
early on we see Winston being summoned
to the Marquee played by Bill Skarsgard
the Continental is destroyed and karoni
shot dead because the Marquee doesn't
want Winston to become a martyr a high
table control the world through rules
and regulations however Jon is in the
front of this because he refuses to
follow them therefore the Marquee very
much wants to destroy the idea of John
Wick he does this by killing all those
who Aid and help him now watching Lance
reddick's character get killed early on
hits differently and as I'm sure you
know the actor unfortunately passed away
last week I can't imagine what it was
like for the creative team seeing that
happen and then having to promote this
movie and watch it back seeing him die
at the start just be very surreal I
imagine sitting in the cinema watching
this play out especially when you knew
the guy and it adds a real layer of
sadness to the film the movie actually
ends with a line dedicating it to him
and yeah it is quite tragic seeing this
all play on screen anyway this idea of
all those helping out getting harmed is
reflected in the Osaka Continental which
is attacked by the high table for aiding
John the henchman here did kind of crack
me up a bit and when they were
introduced I felt like it was that scene
from dodgeball blade
laser
[Applause]
Blazer anyway Wick manages to make it
out of there but the attack is not
without its casualties Akira swears to
get revenge on her father's killer Kane
and this very much plays in the
post-crits scene with my girl Rina she
didn't think that Jon was a bad was a
bad friend and there is potential there
they could spit off with her in the
future I honestly don't know how I have
an audience sometimes it will get worse
and worse every week now my mate Greg
Alba from real rejects he actually
attended a q a for the movie with the
casting creative team and then that they
discussed the scene and what it could be
leading to this is a heavy spoilers
exclusive exclusive exclusive though
unless Greg makes a video on it but if
he does then block him and just pretend
I was the one who went to the Q a shut
the [__] up Ryan Airy now funnily enough
at that Keanu actually said that he
thinks the scene should have been put in
the movie itself and that Akira should
have killed Kane instead of leaving it
open-ended I actually liked that it was
done this way though and the fact that
it was does hint at what could be coming
down the line let me man explain what a
postcard scene is you probably don't
know this because you're a chump but
they're actually used to tease something
coming down the line which is why
they're often not in the movie itself
and are stuck on at the end I think
Donnie Yen completely killed it in the
role and Rina did a great job too so
there could potentially be a spin-off
movie that involves these two Akira is
very much your John Wick archetype in
that she lost someone she loved and is
now getting revenge for what the
infrastructure of the high table did to
her Kane fits them all too and
potentially it may be his daughter
that's killed in a scene accidentally
and then the pair have to face off
against one another that's a very
nihilistic way to look at it and I can't
imagine that she will survive but that's
just how things could be set up if we
look at the John Wick mold Akira lost
her father and if Kane loses his
daughter then we have two opposites who
are trying to stand up against someone
that lost their opponent's counterpart
it's sort of like poetry they rhyme and
I think both these characters would be
great to set a spin-off movie around the
franchise isn't against doing spin-offs
either we know that we had the ballerina
coming along with the Continental at the
Q a the creative team can them that the
former will take place in between John
Wick 3 and 4 and it will likely center
around the riskaroma family that we meet
in the movie Keanu has been confirmed as
appearing in it but the fact that it's
somewhat of a prequel to this film means
that I think he's dead if he was still
alive then they could have placed this
further down a line but they've confined
the shot of the specific timeline for
his Cameo because he can't show up after
the events of the movie they can however
expand on the newly introduced
characters like Mr Nobody and also his
oscar-winning dog she deserves an Oscar
for that I think we probably will see
them again as they were great and I'd
love to learn more about their backstory
the Continental is also coming too and
that's a big release that's due to drop
later on in the air in November it was
announced that this will stream on
peacock in the US and on Amazon Prime
video everywhere else along with this we
also got some minor plot details for the
show as it turns out the series will be
set in the 70s and it will actually work
as a prequel to the events that happen
in the movies and it will follow a young
Winston and watch as he tries to take
control of the titular Hotel Winston
will be played by Colin Woodall and will
watch as he tries to navigate New York
and gain a foothold in the world of
Assassins and we also know that this
won't be a typical TV show and they'll
actually just have three episodes to
give the production a more cinematic
feel to it they have some big names
attached to this project too and we know
that Mel Gibson will be playing a
character called Cormac Katie McGrath
will also play this decades version of
the adjudicator and Ayo mad at a gun
will play Sharon now I doubt we will see
John Wick due to him just being a kid at
this time but they may potentially Cameo
younger version of him that explains
more of his backstory you know that he
was born in the Soviet Union during 1964
and that he was often at a young age
before he was taken in by a friend of
his father This Man became Jon's mentor
and he was then recruited by the
ruskeroma organized crime group trained
by the director and Neil Young City they
could potentially tease at this in the
series with us still keeping the focus
on Winston imagine that the director
will appear in some form or another even
though she isn't in the cast list I
think that would make a lot of sense
when you look at it being a prequel
anyway after escaping Osaka wickets
backing with his family after killing
Scott Adkins killer who looks
unrecognizable in the role through this
though they're able to formally request
to deal with the Marquee which gives
Wick the opportunity to win back his
freedom his settings are agreed to and
the terms are laid out with Winston
getting back his position in hotel if
Wick wins the Marquee nominates Kane as
his champion and Clancy Brown's
heartbringer says that if Wick fails to
arrive that he'll be executed along with
Winston it's all set in place however as
much as he bangs on about the rules the
Marquee isn't someone who plays by them
and he UPS the bounty on John Wick's
head before he can get to the church
during this we get a clear reference to
the 70s movie The Warriors in which the
radio announced gives coded messages to
assassins in the city they even play
nowhere to run which is a great song
that two appeared in the film when the
Warriors won on the run and we get an
amazing scene at the Ark in which Wick
gets hit with cars like it's the like
button a top down Shoot Em Up and lastly
a mountain climb up the steps of the
church it all comes together perfectly
and it leads into a jewel between the
two sides knowing it Kane and Wick had
to take 30 Paces take a shot and then
move 10 Paces closer to each other they
eventually get within 10 and raise their
guns which sends Jon flying to the floor
after he's hit by Kane's bullet in his
arrogance the Marquee takes over Kane
and this is due to him sponsoring him as
his Champion for the game he wants to be
the man who personally puts an end to
John Wick's Legend and he takes the gun
so he can finish him off himself however
Jon never fired his gun in the last shot
and in the end he kills the Marquee
right after he swears that Kane and his
daughter are now free bleeding from his
wounds Jon asks Winston to take him home
and this has an extra layer to it as it
means he wants to be taken back to where
his wife was laid to rest early on in
the first movie we saw her funeral and
John ends up getting buried directly
beside her he passes away on the steps
after saying her name and this
represents his freedom and peace finally
being achieved earlier in the movie he
stated that he wanted the words loving
husband put on his gravestone and we see
that this is the case in the final shot
John had many nicknames like the
bogeyman and Baba Yaga and these will
help to cement his reputation however
what he truly wanted to be remembered
for was being a loving husband as that's
what truly meant the most to him in life
any other movies he talked about why he
kept fighting and stated that as long as
he stayed alive that Helen would be
remembered in the end though he accepts
that death and peace bring its own
freedom and that he can be with his wife
again he did say in the church that he
doesn't know if she can hear him but him
believing that he might be wrong means
that he keeps talking to her things
could be the case in his final words at
the end and he may be believing that he
can see his wife again after having
found his Redemption and allowing Kane
to have a new life Winston the Bowery
King Ponder whether he's in heaven or
hell but I think his death on the steps
kind of gives the idea that he's in
neither the church at the top represents
heaven and down the steps could
represent hell him going in the middle
could symbolize that he's in neither
place he's just with his wife somewhere
in the afterlife I might be reading into
that too much but Reeves has talked
about what the ending means and what
they try to do with it way back when the
movie was announced it was said there
would be a fifth film that this would be
shot back to back with chapter four
however ryanairy bloody ryanairy he did
the research for me and he found that
the director had said that they realized
when they were making it that they'd be
putting their efforts in to do films
instead of just the one if they focused
on just this film they could make it the
best movie possible I think that the
results here speak for themselves now as
for what Reeves said when discussing it
the actor stated whoa you had the
opportunity to do another film because
the audience responds to chapter 3 and
we were like what was the why in the
whoa and when Chad and I was talking the
Y was
and it was John Wick's death for him to
get his piece of freedom in a way that
was the reason to make the movie it
can't just be like let's do another one
it was really about death or a way of
dying you were really inspired by the
hagakua in case you don't know this is a
Japanese code of ethics dedicated to the
Practical and spiritual guide for a
warrior when talking about death it says
that if you're prepared for death at any
moment then you will meet it with
acceptance rather than fear the code
also states that the Warrior's Way is
death does it make sense that this movie
would culminate with that as a theme in
the movie they also mentioned that in
order to die you have to live well Jon
lived well with his wife and thus he can
find peace in his final moments thinking
about her now there's also the
possibility that he's still alive and
there are some clues in the dialogue
that him towards this we have the line
about how those who cling to life die
and how those who cling to death live in
this final moment Jon is clinging to
death but not being afraid of it gives
him a chance to finally live he amassed
hundreds of enemies around the world and
in potentially faking his own death he
can now be reborn and find the freedom
he'd been seeking there's also that
Heaven and Hell question that the Bowery
King asks Winston we don't really get an
answer to whether he's an either and the
fact that he's not might be because he's
actually not dead now I do think that
the character is probably gone and I
think it would be a shame to bring him
back for a fifth chapter that undoes all
of this and then probably just sends him
on a path with his death anyway it's
clear that death is a big theme in this
movie and I think it would be bad to go
back there but then Hollywood is
Hollywood now when re-watching the
movies in the lead up to this it even
crossed my mind this could be some sort
of dying man's fantasy and the movie has
this weird thing in it where it's pretty
much like a Harry Potter story but
instead of wizards we have assassins
completely unknown to the Muggles I'll
not bore you with that [__] but in the
end this does feel like a fitting way to
close off the story of John Wick whilst
leaving the door open for other people
to emerge you ready John
foreign
I think this was a brilliant film with
Keanu at the helm and it was a Showcase
of how much the creative team have
learned since that first film this was a
culmination of all the techniques set
pieces and cinematography that they
built up over the years to deliver an
amazing action movie to me this felt
like it was part of the raid universe
and when I say that I mean it's really a
master class in stunt work choreography
and also dynamism you have brilliant
moments with the whole scene where you
pass over the top of rooms and have a
downward point of view towards Jon that
blew me away as then the steps scene
that immediately follows it and this is
topped off with one of the tensest
jewels ever put to film that last hour
especially is an incredible achievement
in pacing and stunt work that it was
difficult not to just smile along with
the film as it got crazier and crazier
just watching Jon fall down the stairs
for two minutes it hurt my hip bat and
it shows just how much they're thinking
about how Dynamic the scenes are and
that makes it difficult to think of a
recent film let's Top This in terms of
action it also feels like a piece of art
at pointer and the galleries locations
and where the scenes are shot really
Elevate the feel of this movie The
cinematography app points is outstanding
and it's nearly impossible to hate it
when the action's hitting this hard and
locking this good now as I said earlier
I have rewatched all the movies this
week I still think that too is my
favorite it's got lots of big elements
in it and I don't think it has the
issues that this one does which is the
length of it I had a wild ride but
clocking in at almost eight hours it did
have me checking my watch a couple of
times around the midpoint to see just
how much we had left it did Keep Me
engaged though but I think that it just
knocked it below too for me in terms of
where this one's sat in the franchise
you also have little things like the
bodies disappearing on the stairs when
it gets pushed down them it's just kill
loads of people there and then when he
goes back up they're all completely gone
little nitpicks I know but and also
those people in the club dancing away
just watching people get shot in front
of the master they were still in the
groove and they still had to keep on
dancing little nitpicks I said but yeah
just little things like that that took
me out of the moment for a brief second
um before obviously the action and
screen pulled me back in in the end this
is a great swan song for Keanu Reeves
and maybe Donnie Yen should just keep
playing buying characters because he
knocked out the park in both this in
Rogue one Kane is by far the most
interesting antagonist we've had in the
film series and I'm hoping we get more
with him after that post credit scene
also build Scar's God he could have came
off as a Weasley and just idiotic
villain but he did have a side moments
like when he stabbed Mr Nobody through
the hand this movie just keeps hitting
you with big moment after big moment and
like I said it was a complete joy to
watch this is a brilliant film and I'm
sure you can tell I loved it even with
those little nitpicks but in the end it
gets a 9 out of 10. now obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on it so make
sure you comment below and let me know
we are in a competition right now giving
away this Superman 4K box set of three
subscribers on the 15th of April and all
you have to be on the chance of winning
is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the film we picked the winners at random
on the 15th and the last ones are on
screen right now similar to you then
message me on Twitter at heavy spoilers
if you want somebody else to watch then
we've got a video linked on screen right
now so definitely head over there right
after this by the way thanks for
sticking through the video I've been
poor let's see you next time take care
peace